hello everyone and welcome back to the
Havana Tournament of 1965 which is
basically the capablanca Memorial
tournament the fourth edition and here
we have a wonderful game from round 10.
cuddle robosh who I'm sure you guys know
very well uh he contributed a lot to
Modern Theory and uh well the robot
opening is being used quite a lot today
in online chess in in you know a faster
time format some people even played in
classical but
um I mean I'm pretty sure you've seen
Magnus Carlson employed in pretty much
all all the time formats maybe except
classical uh G6 Bishop to G7 is the idea
and I thought it'd be it'd be funny if
Fisher actually employed this against
him but as Carl opened with the four
Fisher play the Sicilian uh here as he
does in every game uh but yeah he's a
very very strong uh Grandmaster he was
already Grand Master for four years at
the time this game was played he got his
title in 1961 and he uh the the reason
it's probably called the robosh I'm not
sure but he did employed against the
former world champion against Max in the
warden Olympic of 1962 and okay the game
didn't start E4 G6 the game actually
started the D4 G6 uh Pawn to E4 and
Bishop to G7 with some C5 ideas uh and
D5 and um in the end the game ended in a
draw so drawing a former world champion
uh at the strength of Max over uh really
was a was a big shock especially uh when
such a such an odd up opening was
employed uh but yeah uh I just thought
you guys would enjoy that now let's
check out this very nice game if you
haven't seen the previous game from this
tournament as I am covering all of the
nicer ones at least check out Fishers
game against the former world champion
vastly's missile from round two it is a
spectacular game first link in the
description below even watch it before
watching this game now that being said
let's check out what Carl robot prepared
for Bobby Fischer so upon the E4 end
visual replies with Pawn to C5 and for
those of you who haven't started the uh
following the tournament from the
beginning uh Fisher is not actually uh
in Cuba Havana he's actually using a
Telex machine to play this um uh uh uh
tournament uh you know from long
distance so okay Ponto C5 we have Knight
F3 D6 and D4 challenging Fisher to an
open Sicilian so characters captures
Knight of six Knight to C3 and of course
Pawn to A6 as usual Fisher employs the
Knight of uh Sicilian Bishop to C4 going
for the lipnitsky attack and E6
transposing into the souls in attack or
later to be known as the Fisher souls in
attack A3 with Bishop D7 and now Bishop
back to A2 we have Castles by both
players uh and now uh sorry castles
castles uh and now Pawn to B5 we have
Pawn to F4 all pretty standard stuff um
Fisher of course wants to Finca to his
light score bishop and the white will
try to create some sort of a
breakthrough in the center so Bishop to
B7 and the immediate Pawn to F5 Fischer
plays Ponte E5 and Knight dte2 we have
Knight b37 and now Knight to G3 so the
pawn is nicely defended Rook the C8 uh
all very very standard moves and Bishop
to E3 Fischer goes Knight to B6 and here
comes the first move that you would not
see uh played today as a theory has
advanced a bit um further than this and
even though it was known back then maybe
uh players just uh were okay playing of
of beat lines okay it's not even an
offbeat line but today no one plays
Bishop captures and B6 it's simply
because the engine says don't do that
the engine says wait for the Knight to
land on C4 and give up the light score
Bishop for that night so that's what we
know
um and you know we don't argue with the
engines but in those days Bishop
captures on B6 was played with Queen
characters and now King to H1 as the
queen delivered to check Queen to E3 you
can see how Fisher already
uh controls quite a lot of the board the
Queen here on E3 is an absolute monster
controlling pretty much the entire board
and there are a few modern games that
reach this position actually where Rook
to F3 was played but here we have
Knights the D5 and it is now as of move
17 that we have a completely new game so
what did Carl robosh had in mind when he
uh allowed this infiltration of the
queen well Bishop capture Sandy five
Fisher says alright my light Square
Bishop isn't going to be much of a star
so let's just trade it Bishop captures
on D5 and now Bishop to d8 the bishop on
E7 is also pretty dead so you want to
shift it over to this diagonal uh Pawn
to A4 now robosh is making his plans
clear he wants the capture here and use
the a file for his Rook The Rook is
coming to A6 or to A7 probably the A6 to
put pressure on the D6 Pawn so Bishop to
B6 by Fisher and now we have uh a
capture some B5 a captors and now Rook
to A6 attacking the bishop and now Pawn
to B4 so you don't have to worry about
Pawn to C4 uh and uh well you could
attack the queen queen to D4 uh for
example is perfectly fine you don't have
to worry the queen is guarding the
bishop and even if you traded this is
the better better for for Fisher so
instead after B4 we have Knight to H5
this is the second phase of the plan uh
robosh first uh put the Rook on A6 it's
a very nice piece controls the the sixth
strength and also puts pressure on D6
and now he also wants to activate his
Queen and Fisher says Nope Knight
captures on D5 uh and uh here you should
play captures on D5 the problem uh or
rather the idea why uh Carl didn't play
it is that after you capture official
will play Rook to C4 and he will stop uh
Queen to G4 so he tried uh winning a
very important Tempo again especially he
played Queen to G4 right away which okay
you're threatening Checkmate you're
gonna capture the Knight on the next
move but it's not as simple because
Fisher played G6 uh e captures on D5 and
now Rook captures on C2 so Fisher wins
the pawn and if you're not absolutely
sure that you can allow this you're just
gonna be down Pawn against Bobby Fischer
which is you know that's hell uh so F
captures on G6 and H captors and G6 of
course taking towards the center but not
only that if captures and G6 just uh
terribly loses tactically I mean you're
just getting checkmated here there's
absolutely nothing you can do
so instead after F captures on g6h
captures and now Knight the F6 with
check King to G7 and knights the H5
check now hoping to get a Perpetual if
Fisher repeats King to G9 F6 but of
course Fisher will not um uh give a draw
so so easily so King to H6 Knight to F6
and now Rook the F2 and this is a very
very important move uh Rook to have two
stops Checkmate the the threat of course
is Queen Tage um uh for checking to G7
and queen H7 Checkmate as The Rook
guards the Knight on F6 but now by
interposing Rook to Rook to F2 now the
Knight is no longer guarded so Queen
Tage for checking G7 and then the Knight
is hanging so you can't go for that Rook
uh a back to A1 was played and now comes
Rook the A8 a very tricky move by Fisher
the idea being of course that if Rook
captures then Rook captures on F1 is
made in one and you you just have to
move the Rook you have to play Rook 8 to
D1 and hope for the best but in the game
Queen capture Sun B4 was played uh Carl
said all right I'll take this
opportunity to grab back the extra Pawn
that I lost earlier uh so hopefully I
don't you know just lose the game
terribly but the game is now completely
winning for Fisher but you have to find
a very very tricky move uh so feel free
to pause the video and try to find this
wild move uh while I give you a couple
of seconds
foreign so uh for those of you who are
able to do it congratulations on always
looking on how to improve your position
even by moving the your weakest piece
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is King to G7 I was
only joking about King being the weakest
piece as you trade off more and more
pieces from the board the king becomes
the most powerful piece on the board so
he's merely awaiting his power you know
grows exponentially uh the more you
trade down but King to G7 now traps the
Knight I mean it's absolutely incredible
that you cannot save the Knight here and
it's very simple why obviously you can
go to G4 and you can go to D7 but look
at this if Knight's the D7 then look at
this amazing Checkmate Queen to E2 now
of course threatens The Rook or queen
captures and once you move the Rook not
just Rook captures on A1 and that's it
there's no defense against Checkmate you
you could capture you you don't have to
capture doesn't really matter if you
capture we can just give up the queen
and then Checkmate to the the white king
this way and also if you try to save the
Knight via Knight to G4 looks kind of
nice as you're also for the the queen
and the Rook uh Queen F4 again threatens
The Rook capres on F1 you cannot capture
because then Rook captures an A1 and
that's pretty much it and if you play
Queen captures on F4 then Rook captures
on F4 again there is no saving the
knight uh you you cannot capture either
Rook if you capture this then it's
Checkmate if you capture this then this
is Checkmate and of course if you defend
the Knight then Pawn to F5 chases away
the Knight and after Knights the H2 Rook
captures on A1 Rook captures and now
Rook to F2 okay white does not get
checkmated but the end game is
completely winning uh there's really no
good way to to do anything about it if
you want to B4 you can even play Pawn to
E4 prevent the knight from entering the
game and that's uh that's pretty much it
it's a completely winning end game for
black so okay you will have to work for
your meal a little bit but of course he
knows that he can't to do this so Queen
captures on D6 was played and now Fisher
just finishes it off with a nice Queen
to E2 and again you can't move the rock
if you move the Rook down Road captures
on A1 we already discussed that Queen to
F1 check runs into a beautiful Checkmate
so Knight the E8 check was played trying
to trying at least something to survive
but Fisher just said thank you for the
for the free night Rook chapter 78 we
have Rook after E1 attacking the queen
and Fisher just played Queen to G4 and
he was in this position on move 33 that
Carl orobash resigned in the game as
there is nothing more to be done here uh
yeah Checkmate is being threatened Queen
characters and G2 will be Checkmate if
you advance the pawn of course it's just
Queen to F3 Checkmate Fall by Queen to
G2 Checkmate and if you defend would
Rook to G1 doesn't really matter Au can
play pretty much anything let's say
Bishop to D4 and once you play something
let's say B4 you could even offer a rook
doesn't really matter just Rook to h8
Black will completely ignore you
whatever you play because it's made into
whatever white plays and now let's say
B5 you will simply sacrifice and after
captors captures deliver a nice Queen to
H4 Checkmate so really really a funny
game where you can see just just how
important
not a modern opening Theory but just
that we've Advanced a bit further in in
the opening Theory where you don't just
uh capture on B6 after Knight the B6 you
know you can't just play this uh first
off it gives the black queen too much
power and the black smooth just come
very very naturally and you can see why
it even achieved everything white uh was
able to open up the a file he was able
to create a blockade on D5 so he
prevented the official from executing D5
we often say that if you execute D5 In
the Sicilian you will be okay and here
Carl even stopped that he opened up the
a file he was able to trade down here
but it simply wasn't enough that uh
opponent C2 was too much and Fischer was
able to nurture his advantage to uh to a
full point uh in this game uh so yeah uh
Fisher doing extremely well in the
tournament we'll see what happens in the
rest of it and like I said if you
haven't seen Fisher versus from this
tournament in round two first link in
the description below it is it is a
positional Masterpiece you guys will
have a better day after checking out
that one uh so yeah that's the game I
hope you guys enjoyed it I would like to
thank uh Frederick cast and Christoph
Market the animated chemist Mr Anonymous
and all games are best for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the Chess World uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day